the thing you used to dread more than
anything else was to take these out of
the box in which you carefully stacked
them up and they accidentally dropped
them on the floor
there is no quicker way to discover what
n factorial means when you start trying
to put them back together in the right
order armed only with your knowledge of
alcohol programs and which order these
things must have occurred in we have
here in the department a legacy deck of
punch cards dating at my best guess from
about 1971 it was left behind by a
statistic student of that era can act in
it just is like a blast from the past
we'll put this on the classic black
background provided by the cover of an
iPad what could be better
old meets new at the top of the deck we
used to have to put a colored card
basically stating who we were and what
this job was about now I think the first
thing to draw your attention to on any
sample of these cards is you look at
them against the light and if you
remember that a card reader is reading
vertically to get its characters boom
run like that not horizontally the most
amazing thing you then discover which
threw me for a while because I'd rather
forgotten it works like this is that if
you now put the card down on a black
background and will use another card as
a ruler just look what happens every
single character and if you look very
carefully as well as the whole pattern
that denotes a character it can also be
printed out at the top of the card
although the printing ribbon was pretty
faded without these nevermind every
single character has got a different
hole punch pattern but there's never
more than two holes that are punched now
that might seem very strange and as I
say I gave me a jolt at all
how
earth does that get converted into a
character code which is going to be a
bit pattern representing an ASCII
character or whatever you can't just
port ASCII character punching down here
if you did you get into all sorts of
problems because some ASCII characters
have got lots of one bits in them and if
the situation is that you chose that
every one bit was a whole some
characters would make this thing look
like confetti it would be like having a
terraform you know the beasts only holes
that the actual mechanical substrate of
the card will be very fragile so this is
the reason that there are various
choices of two holes here out of 11 rows
in total and that gives enough
combinations to give a unique code for a
fairly limited alphabet admittedly but
it works so perhaps another thing to
point out is that these are cards for an
IC L 1900 computer which was mentioned
in the previous video the IC l 1900
series internally did not hold its
characters in 8 bits as would be done
nowadays it held them in 6 bits so
pretty well all of you out there are
familiar with the fact that nowadays if
you like the standard for years has been
that you have a computer whose integers
are held in 32 bits but if you want
those 32 bit entities called words are
broken up into four 8-bit bytes nowadays
it's the bytes that are addressed not
the words and that particular
architecture of byte address machines
been optionally groupable into longer
units to hold either instructions or
integers or whatever that really did
start with IBM mainframes they were the
first to go in for byte addressing and
8-bit bytes ICL on the other hand did
not have 32-bit words with four 8-bit
characters it had
24-bit words with four six bit
characters why are here you cry the
answer is it's cheaper
you've got rather less memory to provide
rather simpler adders to do you only
need six bit adder circuitry not 8-bit
adder circuitry and it's as simple as
that
LCL could make their computers a little
bit cheaper than IBM although they were
arguably as well a little bit slower and
so on so this is what these hole
punching czar all about they are
equating by specialized circuitry in the
card reader to it being able to
recognize these patterns and say oh
that's the 6 bit character such-and-such
and it will put that into a temporary
file behind the scenes now when you're
preparing these card decks
you really did have to take huge care
first of all the yellow card announces
that this is a job for the computer to
do big surprise there there's a new PMS
they're not immune Aversa tea physics
and maths I think that stands for this
is Ken's identifier PMS ka for Ken akin
and I think this thing at the end
announces the global Terminator for this
deck of cards which will come right at
the bottom for our perros okay then
there's a little piece of job control
here basically saying I want the
nautical university executive program
which was our own sort of homebrew
addition to ICL's jaws operating system
and you notice at the end here it says
bye see in this added module to the
operating system you could say how
desperately urgent this job was or not
you were given a certain number of
notional pounds to spend every month for
every user and you could opt to spend
less money and have it run at low
priority but you could either spend it
by a which means I want the job doing
right now or you could say I'll go
overnight and you were charged as a much
lower rate the next card we see here
announces that this is an Algol job the
following cars will be in the Algol
language so this is a signal to the
operating system though to read all this
in but when it's been read in it has to
be fed in to the Algol compiler and the
operating system knows where that's kept
you don't
unlike Unix Linux whatever these days
you don't get very close to the
operating system it's there it doesn't
do much for you except run your jobs you
just have to trust to it more or less
notice here for those of you at all
familiar with things like Algol and
Pascal it's beginning to look fairly
sensible begin that's a reserved word in
the Algol language it's a bit like open
curly-brace in C but Algol use begin and
end instead of open curly and closed
curly notice that it's signaled as being
a reserved special word because it uses
prime or single quote symbols it's quote
begin quote quote precede your quote
that's another reserved word in the
alcohol language and it's defining this
procedure a zero one triple a with these
formal parameters or arguments there we
are then you're sitting in front of a
card punch you type in just like you
would do on a ordinary keyboard these
days except this thing is
electromechanical so it's going to
splash splash splash splash all the time
every character you hit is punching out
holes electro mechanically and at the
same time is hammering out a typewriter
record on the top of exactly what all
these holes mean every time you hit the
return key whereas even on the dumb
terminal you find the cursor going Zonk
back from from the right hand side of
the screen to the left as you look at it
what would happen when you hit return on
one of these is that the card would as
if by magic be taken away from the
punching station and propelled I think
with sort of compressed air to a catcher
tray so one after another you would
build up a stack of cards in order
that would later be fed into the machine
so when it's all completed and of course
the advantage is with having these
things written out on top if you could
see any mistakes on a quick scan through
you can always punch another card and
replace the bad card with a good card
you would end up with a job to be
submitted can stack is a particularly
short one it just seemed to be running
this routine and using it to generate a
small amount of data to be printed out
so there we are a very very small job in
order to stay sane what you need to do
is the following first of all decide
whether your card punch like to have
these beveled corners at the top left of
the top right faintly recall that ICL
and IBM probably did them different ways
around but that was the thing to help
you get your cars aligned and stop you
turning one accidentally upside down and
thereby reading in the wrong hole
pattern in the wrong order you used to
make sure the bevels were in place and
like that so that's one self-protection
mechanism another one that was
optionally available on some better
quality card punches with support at the
far right of the card typically I think
in columns 72 to 80 because these are
ATM cards you could put a sequencing
number here okay you can have them
automatically sequence the numbered as
you punch them out on the card punch the
thing you used to dread more than
anything else was to take these out of
the box in which you carefully stacked
them up and they accidentally dropped
them on the floor
there is no quicker way to discover what
n factorial means when you start trying
to put them back together in the right
order armed only with your knowledge of
Algol programs and which order these
things must have occurred in so all
sorts of subterfuge is used to be used
but the best was to have them numbered
if possible and then if you could afford
one of these things that were actually
card collecting machines where if you
put in a randomized
of cards they could Elektra mechanically
sort them for you I can't recall I ever
used one of those
perhaps I was careful enough or perhaps
the university couldn't afford one I
don't know
another common trick to use which I'm
actually port marker pen markings at the
top of these if you did or you wrote a
word here you could get them broadly
back in the correct order by just making
your patterns at the top look correct
and get them back in in roughly the way
they should have been so here we have
you see a much more substantial Algol
job I think most of this is programmed
there's a little bit of data at the
bottom so would you have one of these
cards for every line would that be kind
of help every line of the program yeah
would have a car line and one one you
could only fit one line for your copy
yeah yeah one lamp guard right at the
end of this Lodge of stuff let's put it
down here as a separate card of its own
you see that magic word end and that is
the final end of the program and just as
in other languages you're open and
closed curly braces can be nested inside
each other so also in Algol the begin
end blocks could be nested inside one
another so that end then is the final
card of the program but then look what
happens you get a full asterisks card
the four asterisks is a marker to say
that's the end of my program but there's
still another section of my stuff to
come after four asterisks you give the
reserved word data and this is such a
simple program I think from what I can
make out it takes these three integers
here and uses them to generate yet more
data which will be of use in some other
programs so that is it there's the data
that's the end of the pack if you had a
program that generated more data for
input to another program a favorite
thing you could do was to specify in
your job control at the very top that
what you would like is not just a line
printer output of your
answers but to punch out another deck of
cards for use in putting it into some
other program later on so that basically
provides you with a set of data to use
with a different row yes and you might
say well why not just pocket in a disk
file you've got to remember this is the
early seventies you did not have a
personal allocation of files on disk yes
then would be a disk backing up this
computer but use entirely by the
operating system full of temporary files
holding your jobs for you feeding them
in an order and all that but in the very
early days you in person did not get a
personal account to hold your files you
wanted to run something later on then
you had to print it out so whereas
nowadays a lot of you know if you want
to punch out date for use another
program you can either use a UNIX pipe
and pipe it directly into another
program or you can use the UNIX greater
than symbol and send it into a file much
more complicated in these days you had
to announce ahead of time that you would
be punching out results as well as
printing them out that's interesting
what would a computer do with a hanging
Chad the admission of Richard Stallman's
name was not intentional I was thinking
of him actually as I spoke I was tempted
for awhile and many of my friends told
me to try this on with you but maybe not
it would tend that the compressed air is
a lot of compressed air used in these
machines to move the cars through very
quickly